you know sometimes i get really bummed
out when the news is like all joe biden
and all hard policy stuff and scotus i'm
like where's that where's that matrix
you know we talked about the matrix and
we talked about some cultural stuff but
it's
i i'm sorry my friends here we go in the
post-millennial
biden begs press and social media to
censor misinformation and disinformation
from platforms quote i make a special
appeal to social media companies and
media outlets he said please deal with
the misinformation and disinformation
that's on your shows it has to stop
and i'm pretty sure he just committed a
constitutional violation yeah because
the government can't incentivize or make
requests of private companies to violate
people's rights that is still a
government violation of someone's rights
so if
i actually actually tweeted this that
the vaccine mandates are a violation of
our right to peaceably assemble
think about it i mean it's just it's
it's it's a it's a it's a um it's a
workaround the government can't use
workarounds to violate people's
constitutional rights so if you have a
city
new york and they say
you cannot enter
any private establishment except for the
ones we exempt unless you get a medical
treatment that violates our right to
assemble joe biden right now is
violating our right to speech by begging
big companies to shut down what he views
as misinformation and disinformation so
while as bad as that is i'm actually
really happy about this it shows you how
utterly pathetic
and desperate they are we talked about
how cnn's ratings were down 91
over last year they're getting less than
like a hundred thousand viewers in the
key demo they have no influence anymore
and in ten years when they're when their
viewers age out of politics
they're done their narrative is over so
what does joe biden do he begs he gets
on tv and says please
he's sitting there crawling amid the
desert begging just water please and
we're sitting there with our canteen
going
no
well these big tech companies might
oblige him for sure watching watching
them back oh that's what they got rid of
the like button on youtube yeah but
because of because of dr fauci and the
biden administration's youtube channel
being just obliterated by dislikes every
time he went on when a politician begs
you and they have no authority it's
really a good feeling he has a lot of
authority and i die and the intelligence
agencies have long extensive ties to big
tech social media so again it is
interesting to see him beg i mean his
poll numbers have also dropped they
dropped 11 points uh from last month
according to the quincy pack poll so
obviously he is not doing good at all
quinnipiac same thing potato potato you
know what i'm saying you're just trying
to be smug right now no somebody
somebody super chatted is the ai censor
looking for the word with because luke
has never pronounced that word correctly
i'm gonna talk about
i'm gonna speak english how i wanna
speak english there's also this other
headline that i read today that said
biden dodges question on covet and
smirks at press conference soon after
rambling speech where he bungled his
testing czar's name and announced plan
for one billion tests and you know how
is that not popular how how are people
not supporting him in his larger efforts
he just looks so lost exactly
it looked like someone needed to like uh
pick him up and yeah and take him
somewhere
that's what i was saying about you know
biden or obama when he said you have to
do this he was like come on let's get
you in the in the chair and really in
the sun with your blanket and you can go
to sleep
there's your warm milk yes
the video you're referencing too luke is
incredible i mean it's like him like 45
seconds standing there like breathing
slow looking down
almost laughing at the ridiculousness of
it yeah ignoring questions it was it was
awful this press conference he did where
he said i can't even i can't even tell
you what he said because it was jibber
jabber nonsense he was just like we
gotta one thing we don't wanna
we don't wanna uh
do um
work into track that wait no we don't
wanna work and i'm just like what is
wrong with this guy
it's because you know what i think you
know that you know happens joe biden is
an old man
to take to say he's passed his prime
it's an understatement
he's what comes after your prime well
he's after his decay yeah he's after the
decay he's now he he you know look with
all due respect to anyone who's older
there's a certain time in your life
where you sit back you smell the flowers
and you just you've done it you've lived
your life joe biden was there
and they needed that warm body and
someone came to him and said joe can you
read cue cards and he was like
yeah and they were like we think he can
pull this off
and then within only a few months he
lost the ability to even read from the
teleprompter and now here we are the
emperor has no clothes you know what i
love though is that as much as we are
all that kid pointing at the emperor and
saying he's not wearing any clothes
there are still people around no he's
wearing clothes he is he is all there he
is sharp as attack
who are you fooling
you know
quinnipiac has his approval rating at 33
incredible one-third of this country
genuinely thinks that joe biden is
competent wow that's scary that's high
yeah that is really high well those are
the true believers that are are not
going to admit that they made a horrible
mistake
by by voting for the guy
but it's
it's sort of this this
it's it's like it's like it's like a
religious fervor that people have for
their guy and in this case biden
and they just they'll watch that same
press conference and say i think he did
pretty good
he made it like
and so it's
what he do to convince that third
nothing well maybe he doesn't need the
third he needs the people the swing
voters that are going to decide whether
or not he matters he's got him
yeah independents have swung for for for
uh the republicans at this point or away
from democrats i was looking at one
study that that tracked the um
party switching from 2016 to 2020
independent uh has become the smallest
faction because they're mostly
polarizing
but the about uh two to one they go to
republicans
so uh maybe it's a little bit too
generous actually it's it's it's it's
it's a it's a bit more independent
voters are becoming republican but a
large amount of democrats are becoming
republican as well even their best their
best of in the party like tulsi gabbard
and andrew yang i believe andrew yang
left the party too didn't he
he started the forward part they both
left the democratic room too that's a
junk party now i don't there's no room
for those guys in the party yeah right
they're pushed out so um are you
familiar with kim iverson yeah she's
she's great she tweeted that she was
going to be she sent her left she's
fairly progressive we've had her on the
show and she's very much left of me and
i'm fairly moderate
she tweeted she was voting straight
republican and when i saw that tweet it
was on the 8th i was surprised because i
was like i
haven't even committed anything like
that and i
hate the democratic party but she said
anything to stop the mandates and it's
not going to be democrats now the funny
thing is i see vosh the the you know the
socialist commentator say oh what a what
a completely shocking turn of events and
i'm just like
are you not upset that you're you're
bleeding out that your center like you
you're you're right flank you are losing
support every day and your attitude is
ha ha
i really think that covet
authoritarianism and lockdowns and
vaccine mandates these are the only
issue
that matters and and all the the blue
checks and and the media
have ignored for so long this this this
boiling up
bottom up culture
of people that are just pissed off and
and they feel violated maybe they lost
their jobs or maybe maybe they just had
personal medical reasons for not not
being forced to
mandate this vaccine i think that's
who's going to show up and i think it's
the beginning of a a new political
realignment that i've hoped to see for a
very long time
authoritarians you've said this a
thousand times authoritarians versus
people that just want to be free to live
their lives yeah and that's why i think
we do see some republicans join the
democratic party those are the
authoritarians yeah the the the lincoln
project types
they just want to be rich they want to
be in control they think you're stupid
my michael bloomberg is he really a
democrat i mean he's bounced back and
forth and he's the guy who thinks you
shouldn't be allowed to buy soda because
you're too fat and i'll tell you this
sure i think people who are overweight
should probably lose weight but i'm not
going to tell you you can't have a soda
you know how am i going to track your i
can't track your whole life it's insane
to me and so what ends up happening is i
might you know on policy issues
be a little bit more collectivist than
your average conservative but on issues
of freedom and liberty i'm like well if
we can't vote for it we can't agree i'm
not going to force anyone to do it and
the democratic party in the left
establishment left has overwhelmingly
become shut up and do as you're told and
adhere to the cult and the collective so
they're losing people they're going to
gain those wealthy neocon types who want
to go to war and want to control people
but now we're starting to see much more
libertarian values and little
libertarian um
civil libertarianism joining the right
and that's i think it's a fantastic
opportunity a lot of people on the left
a lot of democrats don't get that i'll
be talking to people who are like you
know democrat leaning and they'll say
something about the republican party
from 20 years ago they'll be like yeah
well the republicans are the ones who
did this with afghanistan and iraq and i
was like yeah i agree that was really
really bad i would never vote for those
guys
but rand paul i don't know he's he's
against all that stuff
i i liked bernie sanders but he sold out
to the machine
so now that we're seeing more people
like thomas massey and you know rand
paul i'm i'm getting happier with the
republican party donald trump trying to
get our troops out of the middle east
i'll take it i'll i'll take it man
you saw bill crystal uh leave the
republican he was basically one of the
architects of the iraq you know all the
war in the middle east and then he left
and joined the democratic and the link
yeah and the lincoln project i don't
know much about them they're there it
was really funny they're like the
republican party is the party of lincoln
and donald trump has besmirched our name
so we're gonna take the party back and
then you know after 2020 they're like
and now that we're still trying to make
money we're gonna go after republicans
anyway and everyone's like aren't you
the party of lincoln and they're like uh
when it was when when they did children
they went after children too that's
another story
when the when the dust settled it turned
out that they were all just neocons that
had become republicans in the first
place they were democrats before but
they'd become republicans because they
really liked war
and when when trump sided with rand paul
and and the the fairly small liberty
wing of the republican party
that was a shot across the bow because
they lost control at the top
and i think i think a lot of this um
never trump hysteria can really be
described by attempts to to scale back
some of the
never-ending wars yeah definitely i
don't think trump was perfect in that
regard but you know i didn't vote for
him in 2016 when i was looking in 2020
and i saw the timeline for withdrawal
for afghanistan i saw trump complaining
about syria i saw trump openly bragging
about selling weapons to these countries
i was like we're getting a little bit of
honesty in that regard and he is trying
to get out it's the best i've seen in my
life so i'm for it he didn't start any
new wars but that's one of the reasons
they really really hate yeah he was he
was very far from perfect and he never
actually succeeded in getting us out of
afghanistan and i think that was
a strategic political mistake also a
policy mistake on his part
but that's the future the future
is
let's focus on personal responsibility
and individual liberty
and maybe let's do less of this war
stuff
every war that the government declares
and it's not just
the wars uh the war on terrorism the war
on covid has been the same damn thing in
terms of enriching
um the corporate interests that collude
with governments to do all this stuff
against the rest of us and and you know
the military-industrial complex there's
a covet industrial complex and man six
trillion dollars buys a lot of interest
yeah just like the war on drugs the war
on covid the war on terrorism just
breeds more drugs coveted terrorism as
of course there's profit incentives
built within the government and the
larger institutions that corrupt them
that of course profit highly off of
those problems being made worse as
they're being sold to you as they're
going to be the solutions to them when
they're not thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm now don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you